Okay, here we are back on one of my work machines,
and we're going to look at a test case which makes the latest version of GCC crash.
That's not to say the latest-released version,
but the version from their subversion repository that I just built recently.
We can see that this is kind of big, and if we look at it's size,
it's about 40 kb, so actually that's not that big as random test cases go.
Sometimes the bugs that trigger compiler crashes are much huger
like hundreds and hundreds of kilobytes. Anyway, this one is pretty small. That's nice.
What we're going to do now is run a delta debugger on it.
First, let's make sure we know that it crashes,
so current--gcc is what I call the GCCs that I build from the repository.
All right, it seems to have croaked in getinitialdefforinduction
at tree-vect-loop 3222.
An assertion violated inside the compiler,
and we're happy that it did,
because otherwise this might have turned into a bug
that causes GCC to generate wrong code, and we never want that to happen.
The next thing we need is an automatic script
that detects if a particular program has this bug.
I've already made the script. I've called it test1.sh.
What it does is compiles a program at the particular optimization level 033.
and then searches the output for this particular string getinitialdefforinduction.
The reason for that is that we want to be sure not only that we can crash GCC,
but we crash GCC with the particular bug we're interested in right now.
This test script will return 0 to the operating system if it succeeds,
and it will return something else if it fails.
Now what we're going to do is invoke the godelta debugger. This is a little script here.
It makes that work, and it's going to go ahead and try to minimize this test program.
Let's see how it does.
The delta debugger just finished, and no doubt Udacity's excellent editors
have cut out the several minutes I sat there waiting for that to finish,
but it took about maybe 4 minutes.
The point is I didn't have to sit there waiting. Let's see how big the program is.
Okay, it's not that small, but it's about 7 kb.
The delta debugger got rid of a bunch of the junk.
It's still going to be a little bit bad. It's not too bad.
We'll be able to cut down that 7 kb by hand if we want to fairly rapidly--
much faster than we would have been able to deal with the original nearly 40 kb.
One thing you might be saying to yourself is that's all well and good.
John can do test-case reduction for compiler inputs using delta debugging,
but the really nice thing about delta debugging is it works for any text-based input format.
That's really nice.
If we're trying to reduce an HTML document that causes the web browser to crash,
we can use delta debugger.
We can use delta debugger if we're trying reduce the JavaScript program
that causes the JavaScript interpreter to crash.
We can use delta debugging, basically--anything that's text we can use it for.
If we think back to the bounded queue data structure
that we developed a random tester for,
those particular random tests didn't have any external manifestation.
Those only existed as data structures internal to Python.
We can't do delta debugging on those,
because there's no text file,
but what we could have done is before running the random test through the queue,
we could have saved those to a text file--
that is to say just translating the operations that we were doing into strings--
and then once that is saved on disk we can run the delta debugger on it
and come up with a minimal set of queue API operations
that cause the queue to do something wrong.
That would probably be a really good idea.
So, delta debugging is an extremely powerful technique
and test-case reduction is something that we really need to have in practice,
especially since this ties in with the triage idea that I talked about a little bit earlier.
Remember that one of our triage methods is looking at the test case.
Well, looking at big test cases is really hard.
There's a bunch of junk that's sitting in the way,
obscuring the actual features that are causing the system to crash
or otherwise misbehave.
If we can do test-case reduction before doing the bug triage
then the whole process becomes really a lot easier.